in march 2003 while american jets bound
for iraq took off from al-adid air base
in qatar not 15 miles away emerged one
of the iraq war's most vocal critics the
news organization al-jazeera
but al jazeera is not just any news
network
it's funded by the qatari government the
same government who invited american
warplanes to launch from its territory
the contradictions don't stop there
about the last country you'd expect to
lead the charge against fossil fuels is
the fourth largest producer of natural
gas
yet qatar spends its unimaginable oil
and gas riches sounding the alarm on
climate change with al jazeera
finally who supports democracy promotes
a progressive social agenda and lends a
voice to those in need but al-jazeera
located in and funded by one of the
least democratic least progressive and
most conservative countries on earth
in terms of political and civil
liberties qatar is not quite the worst
but well it's not far from it with a
freedom house score of just 25 out of
100 it ranks behind afghanistan myanmar
and iraq
in 2012 a man was sentenced to life in
prison for writing a poem that insulted
the royal family
it censors dissenting opinions online
and has been known to revoke citizenship
as political punishment
women are expected to wear traditional
dress in public and are subject to male
guardianship laws non-muslims must apply
for a license to buy alcohol are subject
to a 100 syntax can only do so from one
authorized company and can only drink in
private
knowing all this you might expect al
jazeera to look like russia's state-run
rt which sows doubt and confusion or
china's cgtn which is just outright
propaganda
instead it's more akin to npr or the bbc
the independent watchdog ad fonte's
media for instance ranks all three among
the most balanced and reliable sources
in fact sometimes to their own detriment
their lack of sensationalism might be
characterized by some as bland dull or
boring
but not only is aljazeera relatively
unbiased it also has some of the best
fastest and widest coverage of any news
network on the planet
so
why
why does one of the most conservative
non-democratic and at times repressive
governments spend millions upon millions
on what is essentially global npr
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the bonus video
about why chinese propaganda fails for
just 15 bucks a year
broadly speaking as countries become
richer per capita they tend to become
more democratic
the more money citizens give their
government in the form of taxes the more
they demand from it in return
again broadly speaking
qatar along with its neighbors are
exceptions
in place of taxes they generate revenue
from oil or in qatar's case natural gas
this allows the government to circumvent
the quote normal political relationship
think of them less as conventional
countries and more as corporations whose
citizens are shareholders
knowing they could perform a hostile
takeover these governments essentially
bribe the population with money rather
than democracy or freedom
qatari citizens are given every luxury
under the sun free access to american
universities electricity water
healthcare pensions low-cost loans
guaranteed jobs land grants and even
direct cash transfers
in 2013 its per capita gdp reached 85
000 us dollars
though in truth this number is wildly
misleading
only about 300 000 of its 2.8 million
residents are citizens 90 are expats who
fill the jobs locals don't want
its gdp per citizen is closer to 500 000
qatar in other words has so few people
and so much money that it's able to
offer a much more compelling bribe
as protests engulfed the region during
the 2011 arab spring qatar remained a
small island of tranquility despite its
rule by absolute monarchy
but besides being richer per capita the
country fits right in among its oil-rich
middle eastern neighbors it shares the
same basic political and economic model
language religion and culture
that's the problem
fitting in has always been what qatar
fears most
in 1990 it watched iraq's invasion of
tiny kuwait with a mix of panic and fear
it could be the next kuwait and saudi
arabia it's iraq
with a population 14 times smaller and
an area 186 times smaller qatar has
always lived in the shadow of its
neighbor
that is until
1995 when a coup forever changed the
course of the nation
the new emir as its leader is known
ordered the immediate development of
what turned out to be the world's
largest natural gas field
before long qatar was rich beyond
imagination and with this money it
sought in a word relevance
since then its foreign policy could be
described as trying to be everything to
everyone
whatever the conflict discussion
organization or war qatar would position
itself right in the middle even if that
meant abandoning all sense of logical
consistency
its goal was to stick out as the sore
thumb of the middle east
and stick out it did
since 2013 qatar has hosted about 100
taliban officials at its own expense
saddam hussein's wife a controversial
indian artist in exile and a former
chechen president were also all offered
a home in doha
at one point it gave assad an airbus
a340
and in 1996 it became the first country
in the region to establish trade
relations with israel
now around that same time by sheer
coincidence the bbc established a 24 7
news channel in saudi arabia but after
it aired a documentary critical of the
royal family the country withdrew its
funding
for qatar this meant there were suddenly
hundreds of bbc trained arabic speaking
and most importantly unemployed
journalists next door
seeing this opportunity it pounced
hiring 150 of the best and brightest to
start al jazeera in 1996.
the arab world at the time had access to
only two categories of news either
english language reporting as told from
an american or european perspective
or locally produced north korean style
blatant propaganda
al jazeera on the other hand was
refreshingly real
for once middle eastern viewers could
hear dissenting opinions on the issues
they actually cared about
by 2001 just five years after launching
it had already become the most watched
arab tv news station
in 2011 it was the first or second
choice of news for 75 percent of the
arab world
the only thing it wasn't doing well was
making money
initially the network was given a 137
million dollar loan to be paid back in
five years
but its uncensored reporting soon earned
it an advertising boycott from saudi
arabia kuwait and bahrain destroying all
hope of profitability
yet oddly enough losing money having no
obvious tangible benefit to its
financier and being located in the
country with no press freedom all turned
out to be the optimal conditions for a
good news station to thrive
first because al jazeera eventually
launched separate english and arabic
divisions the former is given an almost
infinite leash
while the arabic version has been
heavily criticized for its whitewashed
reporting on qatar and bias coverage of
the region its english edition has near
complete editorial independence
while american network showed heavily
sanitized video game-like footage of the
wars in afghanistan and iraq al-jazeera
infuriated the u.s by showing gory
devastation and broadcasting tapes of
bin laden
this continued even after the u.s
secretary of state asked its ally to
quote tone down its coverage a testament
to the station's independence
the entire country including the royal
family has paid a tremendous price for
al jazeera's reporting
starting in 2017 the governments of
saudi arabia the uae bahrain and egypt
imposed on it a 43-month blockade
demanding that it shut down al jazeera
during this time the country lost access
to its only land border suffered supply
chain disruptions causing it to airlift
cows from california for milk and was
blocked from flying over most of middle
eastern airspace
second because the network is funded by
the government it remains immune to
market pressures allowing it to focus on
under-reported stories and avoid
sensationalism
instead of chasing ratings with
celebrity gossip al jazeera publishes
articles on humanitarian crises in tiny
countries and tracks elections and
little-known corners of the globe
at a time when viewership is dwindling
and most news networks are scaling back
their physical footprints guitar's deep
pockets have afforded al jazeera the
best equipment personnel and a
staggering number of on-the-ground
stations
its bureaus which are spread across 50
countries outnumber those of cnn by two
to one
third because qatar is ostensibly
friends with everyone
al-jazeera receives unparalleled access
despite broadcasting pro-palestinian
coverage in the west bank for instance
it somehow avoided censorship from
israeli authorities
at the same time its willingness to show
all sides of the story has consistently
gotten it into trouble
its office in gaza was destroyed by
israeli rockets and more than a few of
its reporters have been arrested around
the world
today al jazeera is a contender for the
most reliable highest quality news
network on any topic in any country with
only one major exception
qatar
twenty years ago the country's relative
obscurity on the world stage was an
asset for al jazeera it could credibly
claim to have no dog in the race no
incentive to report with bias
but as al jazeera itself has helped
qatar emerge from the shadow of its
neighbors and take on a larger role in
world affairs the network's silence on
local issues has slowly become
suspicious
its neglect of issues such as the
welfare of local migrant workers or the
upcoming 2022 fifa world cup has at last
revealed al jazeera's almost singular
red line
the network will host everyone from
osama bin laden to colin powell but it
is still not immune from self-censorship
at home
now you might think the urge to
intervene in al jazeera's coverage of
other issues would eventually prove
irresistible to the government
but while it's true that al jazeera's
reporting is far from perfect it may be
the rare instance where its incentives
align with those of the public
the greater its perception as
independent credible and high quality
the better it fulfills its original
mission to keep the spotlight on qatar
so far the government has shown that it
understands the long-term price for
short-term control and has not touched
the goose that lays the golden eggs
other countries not so much
china is perhaps the epitome of bad
propaganda its diplomats issue death
threats on twitter and its media
channels publish a hodgepodge of
conspiracy theories and mundane press
releases
why is china so bad at telling its story
that's the subject of this bonus video
you can watch right now on nebula by
signing up to nebula you also get access
to a dozen other polymatter bonus videos
and extended content exclusive nebula
originals and for the same low price
curiosity stream
curiosity stream is home to great
documentaries on history science and
technology like this one on one of
guitar's neighbors oman
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
just 15 bucks a year and go watch the
bonus video over on nebula